many of you have plans to take a
vacation this summer but what's the best
way to not get stuck in a truly horrible
rental we spoke with one unlucky
traveler that'd be Sarah Stone Mitchell
who shared her experience on Tick Tock
of a rental gone wrong
we are traveling to
um Bishop Arts District which is an area
in Dallas and we're actually doing a
girls trip so based on the photos I
found this house and I was like this is
perfect the first issue that I saw where
I was like this is kind of odd the
kitchen sink doesn't work one of the
rules in this house was no vaping or
smoking or else there's a 500 fine and I
double checked the rules because when I
walked in I it was a strong odor of
smoke as we kind of explore the house we
walk into the laundry room and there's a
couch that's flipped over there were
stains on the sheets we weren't allowed
on the upstairs balcony because it was
they were doing repairs on it and I said
hey look we can't stay here
yeah Sarah I've been there so a lot of
other people Stone Mitchell said that
Airbnb gave her a full refund and the
group ended up staying in a hotel
instead and in a statement Airbnb said
that they've rolled out air cover for
many guests that's what they call it
this was in May it includes several new
travel protections including a get what
you booked guarantee it states a guest
has three days to report a problem with
the home and Airbnb will find you a
similar or better home or refund you
okay a good experience with Airbnb
myself let's get right to Nikki Kelvin
senior director of content for the
Points Guy UK joins us now uh to help
people out from the get-go Nikki thank
you for being here we've heard a bad
experience but the best option is really
to avoid it ahead of time so what should
you look for in terms of red flags on
the rental listing itself
absolutely well thanks so much for
having me um red flags is really what
you're looking for and doing that work
and research before can help you avoid
some problems so first of all we advise
that you check photos so check them
really carefully make sure they're not
blurry or doctored and that the photos
are a real representation of the
property the next thing is go on Google
Maps it's a great resource you can
actually drop your pin in the street and
have a look at the property from the
outside a real look at that and then the
most important thing is looking at the
reviews but not just taking them for
what they say you want to check who are
the reviewers are those people who are
leaving the reviews have they left lots
of other reviews on different properties
so you want to make sure that they're
real also something to be concerned
about is maybe is a different host
contacting you than the one that's on
the site and also it may be a business
running all of these places so you want
you want to check you want to check a
lot you read about a business running
these things you get that a lot uh
should you be concerned if if it's kind
of a management company or is that
actually a sign that it's a professional
operation
I don't think it's something to be
worried about you do see a lot of these
companies running multiple airbnbs but
the important thing is to check that
there's not a web of different people
um leaving reviews on on a group of
properties so as long as it's a
legitimate company and there's lots of
lots of good reviews being left from
independent people who look like they've
actually stayed at the property then you
should be fine
cool Nikki we've seen warnings about
hidden cameras does this happen often
and what if you think there is a hidden
camera how do you check for one I think
the hidden cameras are a rarity but they
do how can we do these stories of it uh
but definitely something to watch out
for now if you want to get all Spa be a
spy about it the best way to check is to
switch the lights off get a flashlight
and look around the room and you're
looking for Reflections and and if you
can see a reflection uh then that that
glass is likely to be a hidden camera
it's important to say that hidden
cameras are banned anywhere and but
cameras can be in public places that's
okay as long as they're visible but no
bedrooms no bathrooms and and you also
you also just need to uh you also just
need to be aware and check those public
spaces but hidden cameras are always
banned so Nikki if you have a bad
experience at a rental property what
should you do it seems like Airbnb seems
to move very quickly to repair it but
what should you do
the most important thing firstly is to
move quickly so contact your host
straight away and see if whatever the
issue is can be resolved because that's
probably the quickest way so go to your
host and try and resolve the problem and
then go to your rental provider be that
Airbnb or whoever else and they do have
these policies in place to help you but
but the important thing is move fast so
you can get helped quickly and document
everything lots of pictures lots of
notes Mark the times all the contact
that you've had with your host because
that's the way that you're going to be
able to prove to your rental provider
and to try and get help afterwards if
you do have issues that continue
anything you can do if you're surprised
by the hidden fees I always hear about
hidden fees that crop up that people had
no idea or Gail the hidden chores the
great thing about hotels they're like
talking about hotels you can walk out
leave the towels yeah if you want yeah
but sometimes at Airbnb they'll ask you
to take the trash out you got to strip
the beds and by the way you owe this
much more than when you leave yeah and
you're trying to make a flight so you
have to do all that
I'm I'm not sure what's worse hidden
fees or hidden chores they're probably
about about as bad as each other when
you're on vacation but first up again
contact the host be super clear about
what's required of you in terms of extra
fees and in terms of chores and the big
question I would ask which is a hard one
to answer if someone's trying to get
money or make you do something it's what
does that feed that cleaning fee cover
so on these platforms there's usually
they can be quite expensive say what is
that covering and then you can work out
what's left for me to do
all right Nikki we're so glad you're
here I know you're normally based in um
London in the UK but I see you're in
Charlotte just being nosy what are you
doing in Charlotte
um are the the campus of our company
that I work for we're here I can
actually see our lovely office right
outside so we've come to meet some of um
my esteemed colleagues and spend some
days with them before heading back to
London tonight
um Nikki you could have said none of
your business
after I asked her I said oh I hope it's
something not too personal yeah thank
you Nikki Calvin thank you I wish it was
more exciting
thank you so much